[Music]
y'all excited Republican huh that was
eerie
yeah there's a sense I don't know how
you'll react when I do you're all
excited the Republican convention has
begun you gotta let me finish the second
[Laughter]
no this is it finally started yeah
delayed by the storm but it did start
and I'll give you the latest cuz we've
been paying attention and Romney gave a
speech at the Republican convention
tonight to show America that she and her
husband are just regular people like you
and I that was the point in speech yeah
Dianne Romney made the speech while
sitting atop her Olympic dancing horse
prancing she's kind of dressage Boris it
dances today after Pokagon National
Convention this is a big deal New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie gave the keynote
address he gave a speech yeah
yeah Christy intentionally made the
speech terrible so that people would
throw food at him yeah sure he could
detach his jaw this is the crazy story a
group of protesters have been outside
the convention dressed up as vaginas
yeah which may explain the last-minute
appearance at the Republican convention
by Bill Clinton he just showed up he's
now a registered Republican and he
supports Mitt Romney a group of coal
miners in Ohio said that their bosses
force them to attend a Mitt Romney
campaign event yeah yeah you know you're
boring when people would rather dig coal
than listen to you speak think about it
trying to decide
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're good
you're fine please just let me get back
to the bowels of the earth yeah
Mars rover I'm excited about the Mars
rover god bless that Mars rover that's
what I say I don't know I don't really
say that it's a very brave stance yeah
it was yeah
this country's divided but we all we're
all rooting for the old ours rover we
all loved the rope what are you
muttering over this and we all love the
rover I'm I'm agreeing
I'm trying to do a show here norm the
quarter I are over I get listen I got it
in change entertain myself oh man okay
your problem I said during the shows
fine but not before Mother's Milk yes I
got the latest today the Mars rover
broadcast a song by the Black Eyed Peas
will.i.am that's true that's true yeah
yeah so there you have it folks Mars
really is uninhabitable there's why why
you paused you longed there's a new
website I thought this was interesting a
new website that allows you to support
Prince Harry by posting a naked photo of
yourself
the websites called
extremely gullible girls gone wild I
support him there you go
according to a new survey that just came
out 40% 40% of Americans approve of
reading a partner's email if you think
they're cheating yeah yeah the remaining
60% are cheating I know I completely
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this may be the
biggest story yet Cinnabon all right
we've learned you've got to let me
finish the set these are now real amend
oh yeah I got him with this one Cinna
bonds at work developing the new
Cinnabon pizza and then amazing Cinnabon
pizza
yes but also at work developing the new
type 3 diabetes
[Applause]
oh this side much more patriotic than
that